there are some fantastic weapons in the
Call of Duty series the ones that you
race to unlock after prestige the
reliable kill streak earners the guns
that you still think about with a
nostalgic glint in your eye when you
think of quality for modern warfare 2 or
black ops in my previous video I talked
about the worst weapons in the Call of G
franchise from 4 all the way to 20 19's
modern warfare and today it's time to
talk about the best the cream of the
Call of Duty crop these weapons are the
best all-rounders in each corner GT game
so no overpower to Kimbo 1887 s or 725
shotguns that's another video regardless
for the first multiplayer powerhouse on
our list we go to 2007 s Call of Duty 4
personally I'm not really a fan of burst
fire weapons in my first-person shooters
but even I had to admit that in Call of
Duty 4 the m16 was a powerhouse not only
did you start with the damn thing so you
could really hit the ground running in
multiplayer but it fired its three round
verse in a blink of an eye with some
pinpoint accuracy and any two of the
three rounds had to hit for you to be
awarded to kill you think that when
building the create-a-class system that
saved the best assault rifle for you to
unlock last whereas in reality the last
assault rifle you got your hands on is
the poor-performing historical throwback
of the MP 44 I guess we just didn't know
that Infinity Ward was spoiling us with
the best cut in class from the start the
9 by 19 millimetre parabellum machine
and pistol 40 is one of the most iconic
weapons in the world and in call of duty
world at war it dominated the virtual
nineteen forty's battlefield of europe
and asia it's slow fire rate is
basically its only downside in world of
war it featured a 32 round magazine with
each hit dealing at enough punishment
that the weapon was considered one of
the most damaging fully automatic guns
in the game again this was a weapon that
players unlocked pretty early in their
multiplayer career with soldiers getting
their hands on their only level 10 and
it remained a staple in many soldiers
Arsenal often called the most
overpowered weapon in world at war its
infamy will remain as long as Call of
Duty titles continue to revisit the era
there are many weapons that I could
consider some of the best when it comes
to mana warfare to the ump45 was the
modern version of the mp40
the spas-12 was one of the best shotguns
of the franchise but while it wasn't my
personal favorite I think many players
got to experience the ACR either using
it to ditch other damage or being on the
receiving end of its deadly laser beam
the little recall that you could see
when firing the weapon
didn't actually affect your shots as it
was all just visual recoil with a weapon
being able to reset near perfectly
between each rounds which may help to
explain why players were able to use
this to spray you down from seemingly
crazy ranges with it having the lowest
damage per bullet of any assault rifle
in the game the fact that you are able
to remain accurate with every shot meant
that it had a quicker and more
consistent time to kill than a lot of
other weapons and its strengths meant
you could pair it with pretty much any
attachment or use it on any map and
you'd still do pretty damn well with it
the Galil was my favorite assault rifle
in black ops and I don't think I'm alone
because it was a common sight in many
players loadout there are players that
considered it weak or a bit of an
underdog but for myself and many others
it was our go to unlock after prestige
the one thing that many fans of the
Galil remember is that a held 35 rounds
by default which was the most bullets in
class as well as having extremely good
iron sights effectively eliminating the
need for scopes this meant that you had
much more flexibility when correcting
your class either going the route of
extended mags and basically having a
light machine gun with a few of the LMG
disadvantages while turning it into a
suppressed battle rifle and making use
of its fantastic range for those reasons
and many more it's still a weapon I
think of fondly whenever the original
black ops pops up in the words of the
Backstreet Boys the ACR 6.8 is basically
the big brother of the modern warfare 2
ACR except this time instead of doing 20
to 30 damage it was 30 to 45 it was
still a laser beam it retained its good
rate of fire and appeared in nearly
every multiplayer match you were thrown
into most commonly with a suppressor
thrown on the front but many of the ACR
super fans getting the things were gold
garish color at record speeds it was
nice to see that for once the weapon you
unlocked class was actually the best one
in the game the an-94 had a peculiar
gimmick that set it apart from the rest
the assault rifles and black ops 2 and
that was whenever you fired a burst from
your weapon the first two rounds would
rattle off much faster than the rest
that meant when it came to firing
controlled streams of damage towards the
enemy it was much faster and easier to
land all the shots necessary and score
yourself a kill than any other assault
rifle but it's faster than average time
to kill from the to run burst ability
pretty low recall a solid range and
extremely decent damage this weapon
really was the jack-of-all-trades in
black ops 2 as I mentioned in our worst
guns video ghosts is my least played
Call of Duty title but that being said
you didn't need to play much of ghosts
to be exposed to the honey badger it
came with an integrated suppressor
meaning that you didn't even need to
consider stealth when it came to
building your weapon loadout leaving
either room for throwing on an extended
mag or a grip the ability to keep
yourself off of the mini-map meant you
could take the honey badger into
scenarios where it could really shine
medium range add the accuracy and
stopping power to shine above many
passat rifles and getting up close with
its rate of fire would beat out many
SMGs thus
moving that in ecology ghosts at least
honeybadger don't care honey bad you
don't give a [ __ ] it just takes what it
wants it was both a joke and a source of
much frustration during advanced
Warfare's popularity that the bal-27 was
so powerful again had a weird gimmick
with its fire rate after the first four
rounds the rate of fire would increase
by around 25% that crazy rate of fire
paired with its strong damage and range
attributes meant that it was a common
sight for your kill feed to be filled
with a player spraying down large roots
for there be a L apart from the first
day of release I don't think I played a
single game in advanced warfare that
didn't feature the BA L it became such a
recurring member of the Call of Duty
cast that many frustrated forum posters
altered the naming convention of the
game into bow of duty last video I said
that shotguns in Call of Duty for the
most part but either Earth's Sun during
ly good or about as useful as a screen
door on a submarine the 205 brecci falls
into the former category it may not have
been capable of one-shot kills like many
other shotguns but that didn't matter
they only took an extra shot in most
cases and because this thing fights so
dang fast had 12 rounds in its drum a
surprisingly long range an extremely
tight pellet spread the extra shot was
never much of an issue when you pair
this close-range powerhouse with a speed
fight maps and mobility options black
ops 3 had players were able to get in
your face and cause absolute havoc with
the brekkie call of GE players don't ask
for much they just want to hit their
shots and be rewarded with that sweet
sweet hit marker that might be why so
many weapons on this list are those
where the recoil is damn near
non-existent it evens the playing field
making every player feel competent at
the game that's exactly where the NV 4
did in infinite warfare following the
trend of a CRS and honey badgers past it
definitely wasn't the most powerful
rifle but when you've got a laser beam
spewing bullets and you're hitting damn
near every shot that doesn't seem to
matter anymore
it's quantity over quality when it comes
to damage per bullet here sure you can
be hitting harder but with a rougher
recoil so you may be missing those ever
more powerful shots but with the NV 4
though you could hold down the right
trigger until your mag ran dry while
there were specific weapons and setups
that without class this thing there
wasn't a gun excelled more across the
board than this one
not long after its released the BA offer
a number of nerfs as it was by far the
standout powerhouse of world war ii
arsenal
and while it was fantastic then the
thing is still pretty solid now in 2020
again a fast fire rate a minimum recall
made this gun a popular pick it also had
an impressive damage stamp making it's
time to kill one of the shortest in the
game while the 20 round mag might have
taken some getting used to it was
relatively easy to stay accurate of this
thing thanks to its recall and fire rate
meaning you could fight from range or
get up close and personal I think the
best accolade you can give this weapon
when it comes to how good it is is that
the thing felt to nerves in the same
month the game was released if that
doesn't say a lot about its performance
when the game came out I don't know what
does there was a temptation to talk
about the AI cr7 here but it's basically
of the ACR lineage which we've talked
about enough besides I think in the
setting of black ops for the sound 9
millimeter is the top tier weapon of the
game this submachine gun had a time to
kill that was notably faster than the
rest of the arms in black ops 4 it was a
hard-hitting fast firing recall free
bullet hose take a gun like that and put
it on the fairly middle to close ranged
focused maps that featured in black ops
4 and it's no surprise it performed as
well as it did I released the m4
dominated call of duty modern warfare
now we're here months and months later
and the thing is still great sure with
adjustments and some DLC weapons thrown
in it's had to fight to keep its top
spot but when you balance out its time
to kill damage recall and the crazy
versatility that the m4 has this thing
in my books at least is still the best
weapon in the game it's unlocked early
it's very easy to control and has so
many attachment options you can pretty
much turn this thing into anything
except a shotgun
9 millimeter rounds gives you an m4 SMG
SOCOM rounds and a big scope creates a
DMR or you can slap a big magazine on
and spray down half the ground or team
before you have to think about reloading
is it my favorite absolutely not that's
the Odin for anyone asking is it holding
on to its throne by the skin of its
teeth almost certainly for me modern
warfare 2019 has some of the best
weapons in the series and is easily one
of my favorite entries to the franchise
but I want to know what you think the
best weapons are what would you change
about my list are there any others that
you love even though you know they're
not perfect let me know in the comment
section below and if you want to see my
list featuring the worst weapons the
franchise you can click that little
button on the top right if you guys want
a most overpowered weapons list and be
sure to tweet me at a regular Dave if
only so I can complain about
one-man-army new tubing a Kimber 1887
and the pre nerf 75 thanks for watching
and if you enjoyed be sure to subscribe
for all your Call of Duty content both
old and new